this is nasa's perseverance rover
and this is china's jurong rover named
after the chinese god of fire
and these two vehicles are on a mission
to explore mars
the us and china are clearly in a
political competition here on earth
so it should not be surprising that it
has now also become part of the
space aspect
the us is the global leader with more
than 50 years of mars research
about 20 meters off the surface and last
february
perseverance was nasa's fifth rover to
land there
china is the newcomer with a mars
program that started in 2006
but the country has big plans for its
first mission called tian one one
the fact that 101 is an
orbiter lander and rover all in one is a
very gutsy move
for a first mission this ambition makes
the jurong rover different from nasa's
perseverance
so here's what these two vehicles are
carrying and what they can tell us about
the new space race between both super
powers
since this is china's first attempt to
touch down on mars a major goal is to
make sure its rover actually lands in
one piece
and it's expected to happen sometime in
may landing on mars is very difficult
jonathan mcdowell is an astrophysicist
at the harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics
and he's been studying space programs
around the world for over 40 years
it's harder than landing on earth from
space
because the atmosphere is thinner so
parachutes don't work as well
and it's harder than landing on the moon
you can't just use the rocket engines
so the chinese lander that will release
the zhurong rover has an intermediate
solution
using parachutes and rocket thrusters to
slow down for a softer landing
you want to go somewhere that you
maximize your chances of a successful
mission because there's already so many
things that can go wrong
so china has chosen a relatively easy
place for touchdown
a basin in the northern hemisphere known
as utopia planitia
it's where nasa landed its second
marslander the viking 2 in 1976.
it doesn't have a lot of big mountains
or big canyons or
cliffs that the rover might fall off and
so
it's a good first place to try and
explore
since this is old terrain for nasa
perseverance landed in a different area
called the jezreel crater
so perseverance has landed at the edge
of an
old river delta so you have this
landscape which is a mixture of craters
and mountains that are gentle rolling
hills
it's a tougher landing area compared
with utopia planitia
but perseverance is equipped with a more
advanced landing system called sky crane
about to conduct the fight crane
maneuver so it helped the rover hover
above ground
while a computer vision system scanned
for obstacles
these two different types of terrains
mean both countries have packed their
rovers with different scientific goals
in mind
and one of china's main focuses is
getting familiar with the new planet
it has a pretty standard set of
instruments
that will help chinese scientists
understand what it's like to operate at
mark parks
china is bringing better tech to utopia
planitia than when nasa did decades ago
the technology on the jurong rover
is probably similar to what was on
the spirit and opportunity rovers that
nasa flew a few years ago
and it's still fairly modern tech so
this is zhurong's multi-spectral camera
which can take pictures in different
colored filters to study various rocks
on mars surface
there's also a penetrating radar that
emits radio waves
and when pointed at the surface the
rover can pick up signals and collect
data about what's underneath
particularly water ice
like jurong perseverance is also
surveying mars but it's larger in size
so nasa has equipped it with more tools
like a helicopter called
ingenuity that could one day help
explore the planet on a bigger scale
it's the first object to make a
controlled flight in the atmosphere of
another planet
which is a quite an engineering
challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the main goals is to learn about
life on the red planet
and scientists say the best way to do
this is bringing back samples to earth
so perseverance has a robotic arm that
can drill into the surface
extract rocks or collect loose soil the
samples are then put in clean tubes to
prevent contamination
and then these are stored here inside
the rover's tummy
nasa plans to bring back the samples to
earth by 2031 in a joint mission with
the european space agency
even though in some respects the us
space technology is still the most
advanced
the missions that china is executing
are actually very impressive now so
they've been catching up very quickly
china space program has enjoyed support
from the absolute top leadership
since the very beginning dating back to
mao zedong
dean chang is a research fellow at the
washington based think tank the heritage
foundation
and he's been watching china's space
program for more than 20 years
he says the country's political system
is an advantage when it comes to
planning ambitious projects like going
to mars
xi jinping and the chinese communist
party doesn't face
regular elections so china is able
to make longer term decisions
and as important sustain those decisions
and those decisions are financially
sustained so while there's little public
information about china's space budget
chang says it's likely not a small
amount china doesn't provide those
numbers
but what we do know is for example china
has four
space launch facilities that's more than
any other country
china's state funded program makes it
fundamentally different to how nasa
works
the us for example has talked about
going back to the moon
for at least 20 years but with each
congress
and with each president priorities
change
funding therefore changes for instance
nasa's annual budget
hasn't hit its peak from the 1960s
fluctuating
more or less over the years and in
contrast to china
nasa is an open civilian agency it has
shared its technology and fostered a
commercial space industry
which has taken over many of nasa's
launch tasks and helped with space
exploration
so if the jurong rover lands and
operates on mars that means china will
have done more and faster in less time
than the us
this success wouldn't be just a point of
national pride
but would also get the country closer to
accomplishing other space goals
including building a moon base and its
own international space station
china is presenting itself as an
alternative with regards to
the moon and mars most of that is for
political signaling
uh political demonstrations to show the
world who has
a more capable technological base and a
better political system